those two fights and one draw with
Woodley crazy I thought why couldn't he
fight Woodley again they well
that's the that's what he's asking first
of all he's saying why don't I get a
shot at the interim title how are you
giving the interim title to Kolby
Covington who only beat Demian Maia
who's 40 years old who's clearly past
his prime how is how is that good enough
to get him a shot at the interim title
they talked a lot of that's it yeah
there you go basically but that goes a
long way at the same time yeah it goes a
long way this day and age but at the
same time with RDA you know they're not
doing Kolby any favors send them down to
bruh I'm sorry it's in Chicago yeah
Chicago to fight RDA which is if you
look at Kobe style it's probably the
worst matchup for him he's a heavy
underdog so I'm hoping not hoping I
think what the plan would be RDA wins
that fights Woodley which is tough
matchup for Woodley and then RDA were
able to beat Woodley then you have
wonder boy slip in or Colby wins and
then you got mad talking with him
and Woodley and it gets very interesting
get she's bad like that fight like fiery
and Tyron Colby's the underdog in every
one of those nights
yes but RDA Woodley you got a barn burn
and that's a great matchup yeah RDA
Woodley is very interesting because it
cuz as much as as they you know I love
woodland I think his style is ridiculous
he can be tough to beat you know I think
they want some bit of turnover in there
they want some turnover what is RDA
gonna do it to Woodley I mean you can't
down
no he's the only thing he's got strong
on a striking and his movements good and
if it does go to the to the ground and
his kicks would be a tough one to beat
for anybody yeah striking even Rd a
striking Woodley has I'll put you to
sleep instantly striking well there's
more power RTA has better fundamentals I
would say as far as putting more time
running together kids speed the power
and the explosive enough goddamn
nightmare no he wants it - Woodley just
got through shoulder surgery he just got
his labor repaired which is not the
worst shoulder surgery and he does that
mean exactly stapled the labrum back to
from no the labor room he had some sort
of a tear in it that that up in
the day me and Maya fight like instantly
they stitch it back together again but
he's gone through crazy PRP and all
kinds of other now he put up a
video of him hitting mitts and it's only
been about three months since the
surgery and he's hitting MIT's hard I
don't know if that's an old video though
he's sneaky you know he put up this
video
he's a for him though he might he might
be doing you know sections of this who
definitely got some injections he was
talking about all the different things
he's gonna do for as far as their he
came on the podcast just a few weeks
after shoulder surgery and he was moving
around normal and moving his hands
around normal but it really depends
entirely on how bad this the big one is
the bicep tendon when the bicep tendon
gets torn off the muscle or off the bone
and then they have to put it back in
staple it down everywhere and then they
have to it does work right now now does
not for pitchers if you're a pitcher and
that goes south not good you're
diggity done but for a fighter
no problem doesn't seem to be a problem
for fighters but I bet Woodley so you
got RDA
Colby so the obviously the winner that
will fight what the end of the year will
it be back into the year no doubt yeah
it could very well be on the December
31st card you know that's a big one huge
good you know I mean I think they were
trying to talk about him being on the
August card in LA but doesn't happen